did you watch the Oscars I did what you
think didn't watch them don't watch any
party I'm not invited to but I'm glad
parasite won but I also was hoping Joker
will win of course not because I'm in it
but because I think it's well Joker
Joker won best actor of course yeah I
mean if sight one I haven't seen peer so
I can't really great movie no great
movie hey dude I saw reason I know how
that was so crazy random I don't think
there's anyone it's pure sight is yeah
I'm have to watch my favorite movie that
that and joke are my two favorite movies
though I didn't watch stroker but after
you Joker's fantastic oh so joke is so
good
I got Joker actually is ultimately
better but para says I'm glad this
Korean movie won he must be a national
hero oh my god cuz you're representing
Korea I mean [ __ ] it's all yeah yeah
Korea came over to holla yeah took oh
that's so great my boy a brad pitt one
yeah about time right did a great job he
did a great job in the pauses like that
acting of doing of doing nothing was
amazing like he just I don't know that
the pauses he won for he won for what he
didn't say and how he was so good yep he
told Leonardo's I'll ride your coattails
anytime man sorry say yeah wow it was so
good wow that's amazing man that's what
Netflix loses down on pretty much
everything damn you didn't saw the
picture but what picture on I can't find
that you can see Laura Dern and that I
love Renee Zellweger my girl won for she
just wins Oscars whenever she decides to
act Renee took what 10 years off and was
like I'm gonna come back and do this now
I just saw the beginning of Judy she's
great in that yeah it looks different my
friend said she's gonna win I was like
Jimmy Broncos just give it to her now
damn it's such a big deal god damn what
a comeback for Renee I have no desire
through that marriage story it's just
two people arguing [ __ ] yeah Adam driver
yeah he's fun Amin I heard it's really
good I saw Adam driver on stage she was
really phenomenal who won Best Director
oh yeah course I'm sorry boy
yeah and that won best film too yep
that's why it so it was shot like it was
shot that's what I would call you to
watch it running because you
get it the way looks on Phil I know I
want to get man I shall wait to comes up
[ __ ] good she be seen Jojo rabbit no
I want to see her tits so good
Jay loved Jojo rabbit Wow nine nineteen
seventeen one for what I've seen a lot
of these movies cinematography I heard
that's amazing - Wow American Factory Oh
best documentary I gotta see that all
the documentaries man another
documentary i watch her up there there's
a new documentary for Malcolm X on
Netflix oh really
yeah it's like that conspiracy behind
his murder I love this guy who's just
balls deep in the murder of Malcolm X I
watched part 1 last night it's so
interesting
really oh it's so interesting I'll tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]